please please welcome a young thank you
thank you
so yeah Marco I do agree about my title
protein design by multi objective
optimization it's quite a my quite a
mouthful and I said to myself a goal
that by the end of these thirty minutes
you'll have an understanding of what I
mean in order to do that I set up like
three takeaway messages for you to take
home the first is I'll describe what
multi objective optimization is in
general terms and why it yields better
results than when optimizing for what
I'll define as one dimension
optimization the second takeaway is I'll
give a list of characteristics that that
I'll give you intuition for when you can
apply it
meaning that you think of your own
projects that you're working on is this
relevant for you and in the third I'll
show how I'm a data scientist in a
biotech company called la genius and
I'll show how we apply machine learning
and multi objective optimization in
order to improve the efficiency of how
therapeutics are being discovered a few
more words about that today we live
healthier lives in the past due to
advancements in therapeutics but the way
in which new drugs are being discovered
is very it's much more risky than it
used to be it's much more common it's
much more expensive and takes much more
time for the reason that many candidate
molecules they fail in various stages in
the R&D and testing pipelines the reason
is that there are many characteristics
that proteins have to pass successfully
and it takes only one parameter for it
to be rejected and R&D and testing cost
a lot of money millions and billions of
dollars and sometimes it takes
pharmaceutical companies years until
they find the pain points where it might
fail this is an example of big pharma
from big pharma company from 2016 in
which they thought that they had an
antibody that could reduce cholesterol
levels and only after a year long
third third stage test did they realize
that it lost efficacy on patients and
then they had to stop testing the drug
and eventually they had to retract
claims in which they thought that they
they had forecast in which they thought
that they would have half a billion
dollars in revenue and for this reason
in in lab genius we are working with
with with partners in order to make the
process of figuring out which proteins
are most likely to succeed more
efficient and we're doing so by means of
machine learning and multiple objective
optimization the topic of this talk as
applied on empirical data of proteins
that we're synthesizing in our
laboratories so the first talk the first
part of this talk will not be about
biology at all it will be generic about
multi objective optimization in which
I'll describe what it is and how how you
can apply with in particular with
genetic algorithms and then I'll talk
about how at lab genius we apply this
for a protein design for the sake of
therapeutic discovery hi my name is al I
am I've been working lab genius for the
past year and a half I am a physicist by
training I transitioned to data science
five years ago and this is a point to
thank the organizers of Pi Day to London
throughout all the years for creating
this environment of meeting people and
sharing knowledge in Python and data and
I'm glad that I can contribute something
that I learned in this past year
one last introduction introduction slide
I work with an interpreter
interdisciplinary team and I just want
to highlight two true unicorns that I'm
very fortunate to work with Meena just
finished a half-year internship with us
in which he worked both in data science
and software engineering and Katja she
is an expert in machine learning in
biological experimental data okay so
with that intro I'm ready to start
optimization means different things to
people here I'm plagiarizing a
finishing from a book that I found I'll
just read it out the procedure of
finding and comparing feasible solutions
until no better can be found yep that
pretty much sums it up that makes sense
right most real-world problems you're
going to deal with more object more than
one objective and they will be in
conflict just imagine you want to
optimize for the quality of a product
why you want to take into account how
much that will cost right so they kind
of contradict each other
throughout the talk I'll also talk about
the knapsack problem in which you have a
bag and you're going to put in it
packages of different weights and values
and your objectives are to maximize the
value of the bag and minimize the
weights in or in order to have a
footfall discussion on this you have to
imagine two spaces of interest we have
the decision space those are the
parameters that you help from full
control of the knapsack problem
those are you make the decision of which
packages to put in the bag and then
you're going to have a mapping to the
objective space that's that's the
parameters that you're interested the
the total weight and the total value of
the of the bag itself you know a topic
is interesting if there's an
illustration in xkcd and so I like very
much this subjective this distribution
of fruit and you'll all agree with me
that if we want to optimize for taste
according to this we're all going to
choose peaches right and if we're going
to optimize for how easy it is to eat
the fruit then we will give the author
of xkc they will offer them seedless
grapes but the point of this is how are
you going to do multi objective
optimization you want to optimize for
both parameters so just a raise of hand
who thinks that you're going to offer
the peaches nobody all right who's going
to offer the seedless grapes all right
we have a few people in hand and any
other ideas we're also going to suggest
what's that
but here I hear here bananas okay no oh
that's that kind of suboptimal well
you're from Colombia so that maybe
that's why yeah alright alright so
basically it's a it this hat another
option is strawberries if you go like
along like a 45-degree line it's implied
I'll take even weight but actually it's
it's was a trick question
according to multi objective
optimization there is no one up what no
one optimal solution but rather a set of
trade-off solutions that are equally
optimal and that's what we'll call the
parental front I'll get back to this
point later on but let's kind of see
what we were analyzing in our head in
our heads and this is kind of what a lot
of biology labs do around the world in
other experimental environments you have
this subjective space you want to
optimize for two or more parameters
throughout this talk all the images will
be in 2d but take into account that you
can extrapolate this to n dimensions
this is a space this is the space you're
interested in and you do your experiment
that's your flashlight in which you
navigate in this space the question is
what's the most efficient way to
navigate I'll present here to what I
call 1d approaches the first is called
linear and which you just maximize One
Direction you maximize a second
direction and you say okay this is my
optimal solution now you could
alternatively go through this turret
this trajectory and choose this one a
second a second thing that you can do
it's what it's called single objective
optimization in which you you come up
with a metric that combines both
objectives in this case I'm giving them
equal weighting we're going along this
trajectory and then we're selecting this
as our optimal solution but just looking
at this you can appreciate that
this is really not satisfactory right
there's a lot of space that a lot of
unknowns over here because we designed
our experiment in this fashion what you
would want to do is you want to turn on
the light and look at the full objective
space and create a full map so such like
when you're designing the next
experiment your domain expert in my case
a biologist will point out well actually
I think with our next experiment should
focus on this area right over here and
that's the purpose of multi objective
optimization and what you want to
explore the full space and that way
you'll get close to the true optimal
results and again Oh again what's the
difference but what's the difference
between the two approaches that I'm
describing in the one the optimization
we set strong priors to the space that
we're going to be searching and the perp
in multi objective optimization what
we're doing we making that subjective
decision at the end or you can imagine
once you're familiar with the space you
can do it in a more interactive fashion
making decision throughout again back to
the point of fact that we're not looking
in multi objective optimization we're
not defining one optimal point but
rather we're looking for a set of
trade-off solutions there's always going
to be a trade-off for example over here
we have two objectives we want to go
over here but what we'll have is we'll
have a front of trade of solutions that
we call them equally optimal later after
we finish the search that's when a will
will Bret will decide which focus were
most interested in based on all the
feasible solutions that are out there
how do we how do we how do we I'm sorry
so this front over here it's also called
the Pareto front or optimal front named
after the economist from the 19th
century how do you how do you
mathematically define the difference
between the the Pareto front to the
others well the idea is that the the
optimal points they're what's called non
dominated that means there's no other
point that dominates it in all the other
dimensions let's take for example K over
here K is dominated by D both an
objective one and an objective two as
opposed to D which is dominated by C at
objective two but not in one and it's
dominated by an objective one but not
two so there's no other point that
dominates D in both objectives and hence
it's part of this optimal front another
nice aspect of this is that we don't we
can be agnostic about the scalings of
the two objectives for example if you
imagine the knapsack case you have
weights and values but what if you don't
know how much the weight is worth in
monetary terms so you can be an agnostic
about that and make those decisions
after you explore the full season
solution space I pretty much finished
task number one hopefully you have an
appreciation for what multi objective
optimization is what I mean by that is
that you're optimizing not for one point
but for a set of trade-off solutions
called the Pareto front and this will
yield better results than well then one
the optimization because you're
accessing a much larger search space the
reason you're doing that is because
you're keeping the prior constraint
sorry you're not setting priorities but
you're making your decisions after the
search yeah so that's the first thing
that I want to convey the second thing
is it is applicable for your own
projects that you're working on I've
been thinking about this and so far I
came up with this checklist of things
that you'll be needing the first is
you'll need you'll need a full control
of your decision space and what I mean
by that is that for example I always
imagine multi objective optimization in
terms of food delivery companies right
they have three objectives they want to
satisfy the people at home they have the
restaurants and they have the delivery
personnel and I was really excited when
I first met for the data scientist from
one of the big company delivery
companies here and I want to know all
the details about what they're doing and
then I realized in there particularly
Department they don't do multiple multi
objective optimization for the reason
that that they have no control over the
orders that the delivery personnel take
that's something that they don't have
control over so that's why I came up
with this part of list the second thing
is you want an inexpensive mapping
between the decision space and in the
objective space for example you want a
model that you give it the the
parameters from the decision space and
it will immediately give you a result if
you have to go into the field and it
takes time to get your results then it
might not work for that particular
project but basically that's all you
need and once you have that you create a
map of the distribution of solutions and
then you go to your domain expert to
design the next experiment so it sounds
very simple but I purposely neglected
one crucial fact is what is the size of
the search space that you're looking at
most likely you have an intractable
search space like the knapsack
problem the more packages you add it
increases factorial e and when we look
at DNA sequence base well you can
imagine well that's just something
ridiculously large and we need to use
stochastic algorithms in order to
address that for that purpose we find
genetic algorithms are very useful the
reason is that it deals very nicely with
combinatorial spaces and it provides
multiple solutions that are diverse in
the next few slides I'll go over this
diagram over here this is one
architecture of a genetic algorithm in
which the main operations what what you
have is your solutions you call them a
population and it's motivated by
Darwin's theory of evolution in which
you have operations like selection
crossover mating which I'll get into so
first thing you have to do you have to
initialize your population in the
knapsack problem you can imagine that
you just have virtual knapsacks and you
just fill it with different different
packages and in our case what we have is
we have in this case protein sequences
in red I'm just highlighting differences
from a protein that we know that works
in the wild something that we call the
wild type after you initialize the
population then you want to score for
them that's not that's our objective we
wanna know the fitness of each of them
and you start building these
distributions and then the next step is
you before your selection you have to
define a termination criterion can be
like number of generations or reaching a
certain region in your objective space
and then you want to select that
population for example a naive approach
would be oh I'll just take my Pareto
front right my set of trade-off
solutions and you know that's actually a
very naive idea because you might have
only a handful of solutions over there
that will minimize your diversity so to
take that into account there various
algorithms out there that will that will
take all these things into account for
example there's a thing called elitism
that it takes into account in which the
selected group they are the parents of
the next generation they will produce
children via crossover mutation
just like if I only buddy in the movie
Highlander in which they can propagate
to the next generation and they don't
actually die that's what elitism takes
into account and there's various
interesting other aspects that these are
within these algorithms to be on this
talk the next thing the next thing you
use the selected population they're the
parents of the next generation and then
you create children by crossover in the
knapsack problem you can imagine just
switching half of the of the packages
and in the case and then oh in sequence
is what we'll deal with like chop
sequences in half and just combine them
and in mutation and knapsack you just
take out packages or put them in and in
the case of and in the case of sequences
you'll just change one letter for
another in the next state so after you
pass you a turbine I should Criterion
great now you have a list of optimal you
have a list sorry a list of solutions
that you didn't have before and they're
all scored for and you have a mapping
you'll show it to your domain expert and
together you'll figure out have you
gotten the final solution that you need
or you want to go and do more
experiments and I'll get more into this
point later but for now Zack you kind of
took the Thunder away from me when it
comes to animations but I'll do my best
over here to entertain you with with a
few here I'll just show an animation of
God doing this full loop in which this
is iteration number one and this is this
is a toy model and it's also a very nice
non realistic in the sense that I
purposely made the objectives actually
be aligned in which there's not much
conflict in it just to show you what it
looks like I you're up to you're
maximizing objective 1 minimizing to x
marks the spot that's where you want to
go according to this the peretta front
is just this one solution and just
imagine this as a kid with a ball in the
field and everybody's just trying to
jump on them so you can see this is
really not really this is what you'd
hope for this is the ideal this is what
you want but in practice what you'll get
is something more like this maximizing
both of them you want to get to this
point the now you have like a much much
diverse peretta front here in blue and
all the rejects are the are the squares
and you'll get something like this in
which you see they're trying really hard
to get here but this whole region over
here is probably not feasible according
to this toy model and what you'll end up
is something like this and then you'll
sit with fear with your domain expert
and you'll sit down and say oh maybe
this I maybe this is where subjective
subjectivity comes into right it's after
the search then you make the subjective
decision and you might select this one
for example great so I just want to give
a shout out to the developers of deep
it's a Python platform for prototyping
evolutionary algorithms hence it's very
useful for a multi objective
optimization and they make life very
simple this is just a snippet of code
that I wrote in which I'm feeding their
tool box registry functions that I
created for crossover mutation
evaluation and the most complicated one
which is the selection I didn't even
have to code myself
they have like state of the art
selection functions that I briefly
mentioned before and I finished with
task number two take take away number
two
I gave description of how to figure out
if multi objective optimization is
relevant for your projects you need
control you need full control over the
decision space you need inexpensive
mapping to to the objective space and
and if you have an intractable large
space you need a stochastic algorithm to
search and I talked about a genetic
algorithm which is useful to do so now
I'll get on to what we actually do in
lab genius in which we apply these ideas
to protein design in order to make
discovery of therapeutics much more
efficient we are a biotech company
london-based we're in Bermondsey which
is south of the teams we've been growing
really fast in the past year I joined as
employee number 12 now we're over 30
here I'm showing our laboratory we have
I think over 15 biologists
in which they are designing building
testing for selection of various
criteria of proteins and in addition we
have automation engineers that are
helping them having robots take over the
repetitive jobs that they need to do and
they're also the robots are taking over
the night shifts the biologists never
had enough sense but the robots are and
this is what our organization looks like
from the point of view of the tech team
although here is where all the
experimental design is and they sequence
the data I mean they they digitalize it
in which we clean it we do machine
learning and the focus of this talk is
library or protein design and we do this
in an iterative fashion in which once
we're happy with the result then we'll
send it to our partner to develop a
protein that we think will be successful
for the created therapeutic proteins
come in different shapes and sizes
fortunately they all have the common
building blocks 20 natural amino acids
in which we can describe them in a
sequence with just a character this is a
combinatorial challenge if you take two
amino acids that's 400 combinations add
a third one that's already 8000 it's not
uncommon to get to a hundred sequence of
a hundred that's already more
combinations than there are atoms in the
universe what does our data look like
I'll start with an apology because of
confident confident yet confidential
reasons I sorry I yeah I'm not gonna
show labels on the data and I'm actually
not gonna show actual data from our live
from from our lab but rather some proof
of concept that I did on public data but
everything I'm describing is is similar
to what I'm applying on the actual data
from our lab so the data that we're
looking at is in this case here I'm
showing amino acid sequences where again
the red is highlighting differences from
what we call the wild-type something
that we know works in nature and it's
scored for various protein properties
so this would be our decision space and
this is our objective space the protein
properties that we're interested are
things like stability of for various
screens binding affinity
manufacturability then we apply machine
learning where what we're interested in
is linking between DNA sequence to
protein function this is a whole talk
within itself
they'll have scope for it right now but
the purpose of this slide is to show
that if you have clean enough data and
signal you'll be able to create a
reliable model you know we're looking
when we look at various data sets we see
accuracies of above 82 like 95% IU C's
of above 0.9 and here I'm just showing
binary classification in which we have
out of box data looking at positives
clearly predicted to be as such okay
great so the machine learned the
question is how do we propagate these
learnings to to the biologists in the
lab so they can design build and test
for it for and for that we build a
sequence optimizer and what it does it
takes the wild-type or takes a protein
sequence that's our hypothesis of what
we think will be useful and then we'll
ask the model for prediction but we
don't only do limit ourself to that will
actually look at a whole so a whole
large space of signal of sequences and
ask for their scores as well and then
we'll compare them and then we'll
suggest and improve candidate for even
the next experiment or for the client
but of course we're not going to look at
one function at a time this is we're
talking here about multi objective
optimization there's a whole list of
things that we'll be interested in and
so here I'm just showing three but you
can imagine more functions that we're
asking for the scores and hence we're
applying the multi objective
optimization in order to get and improve
candidates and make sure that we go over
a full list of functions now I'll show a
few slides in regard to a case study
that I've been working on the data here
is and binding of antibodies the amino
of the
they are 200 amino acids in lengths but
in the training in the data there's
actually only 20 locations in which are
mutated but that's enough to get a
search space of 10 to the power 26 so
clearly something that you want to use
stochastic methods with and just to
describe what you this visual over here
this is what I call the frequency matrix
this is what the data actually look this
is one way of representing the data in
which here's the 20 positions and in
position number 1 for example most 90%
of the sequences are T and that's kind
of the water that's what we know
actually works in nature this sequence
here is what works in nature and then
you can see the rest of the 10% are
distributed amongst the other 19 amino
acids so that's the data that we have we
built the model based on that and then
we want to like tweak these a bit and
suggest different sequences then this
wild type and see if we can find one
that performs better and this is an
animation that we see sorry this
animation is from the genetic algorithm
this is going through the decision space
and the way to read this is that is
before I showed I showed here the
frequency and here I'm showing the
change in frequency and the way that I
read this is that over here for example
where it's zero it likes it agrees with
the previous sequences frequency so it
it prefers here the wild type and all
these just show that the wild type is
being rejected so over here Y is being
rejected and it prefers s-sometimes K
and so on just to show you the initial
the initial distribution here you can
see like half of the time I'm using the
wild type in half the time I'm using at
random all the rest so I select this
very randomly and then that's when the
machine learning kicks in machine
learning is already set and I'm asking
for scores from it and then it's pulling
in different directions that's what the
decision space looks like what does the
objective space look like I'll just
rewind this oh sorry
all right there you go so you could see
that it quickly started over here is the
objective is to get as close as possible
to this point like over here I should
have marked it
and X and you can see the Pareto front
like pushing its way pushing its way
over here the squares scores are the
rejects the selected are in red and when
the selector becomes the final peretta
front of the 160 iterations that's
that's when it turns reading that means
it's not learning anything in that
region anymore and another thing that I
added which I like is what I call the
graveyard
those are the ancestors of all the
popular of the current population in
each iteration and that's useful to
preserve so you can do analytics later
on great so you run multi objective
optimization and you create this map
what do you do with it you go to your
domain expert in my case is the
biologist and well they have to decide
what they're going to select for the
next experiment if it's something that
we're going to give to the to our
partner or it's something that we have
to go back to the lab and find better
solutions and in this case we just
highlighted well this is where we want
to go but there's no feasible solutions
over here and so we have to do the next
best thing we just carve out solutions
over here and that's why you see these
streaks actually I want to go back and
figure out more sequences over here so
we can go back and test for these
another nice aspect of this is the fact
that we go further away from the wild
type which is done in regular in in
standard biology labs just to explain
what that means what we measure is the
Hamming distance from the wild type and
in the training data is here in gray so
you can see the training data goes until
a distance Hamming distance of three
normal laboratories what they do is they
don't go too far away maybe four or five
amino acids away from the wild type and
here what we show that according to our
machine learning model we can easily go
to about out of twenty we can go to a
distance of about fourteen and that's
what you saw and it's a decision space
you can see it went very far out and
this subset selection is here in pink
all right just checking on time so I
have a few more slides but which I'll
breeze through but that's pretty much
what I want to describe there are
various other aspects of more more
details in multi objective optimization
it's a really fun topic
and things you have to worry about it's
for example it's the diversity of the
population all you have to worry about
local minima you're dealing with the
stochastic algorithm so how do you deal
with that and it also has its own hyper
parameters how do you even do a tuning
for that so the answer to all of this is
first of all you want to visualize as
much as possible in order to do that you
want to log everything so that you can
do your analytics these are just a few
visuals that I find useful for example
per iteration I'm looking at the
objectives of the selected in green in
the rejects in red here I'm looking at
the diversity my population here I chose
is 20 individuals that I make sure
that's a straight line if I have
duplicates then it will quickly drop and
that's horrible because that means that
all the children are based on the same
parents and you know that's never a good
idea this is a this is this is an
analogy this sine x squared of the the
problem of local minima so imagine that
you start around here then you end up
over here what you want to do is you
want to do niching that means you want
to start in various locations that way
that you can look at the final results
and get all the all the minima another
thing that you want to do when it comes
to the fact that you're dealing with
stochastic results well you just want to
the simplest thing is just too many seed
runs because you'll always get a Pareto
front when you combine the results of a
different runs for example over here
here's three repeats different different
color codings
where in in the triangles are the Pareto
front when I a great everything together
so we repeat number one it actually has
38 here marked in blue but most of them
are X's meaning they're being rejected
by the final Pareto front and only five
of them contribute to the final period
of front of 30 individuals just because
it's fun to watch these animations this
is what a similar result looks like when
I stuck together 10 seed runs of two
different configurations five repeats
each so it's always cool to find out and
learn like how they were how the
evolution took place that's all I had to
say
about multi-objective optimization just
one short community announcement we are
looking for a bio and fermentation
Biron fermentation to help us analyze
our new generation sequencing data if
there's anybody in the audience who
actually knows what I just said great
talk to me we're hiring if you don't
that's fine in a few months time we'll
probably be in the lookout for data
scientists as well just to summarize
this talk hopefully you all understand
what a protein design by both the
objective optimization actually means by
now I talked about multi objective
optimization in the sense that you're
optimizing not for one solution but for
a whole set of trade-off solutions that
are equally optimal until you apply
you're waiting after the research and
the reason that yields better results
then the standard one the optimization
is because you're exploring a much
larger space I also showed I also give
highlights of indications of why this
might be useful in projects that you're
working on it's if you're dealing with
conflicting objectives which is most
likely the case if you have full control
over your decision space and you have if
you have an inexpensive mapping to the
objective space and I also talked about
how in lab genius we're applying the
concept of multi objective optimization
to make the scrub discovery of
therapeutics much more efficient I will
just finish with a few resources which I
found very useful in order to learn this
topic basically anything that ecords
isler wrote since his PhD I highly
recommend probe for prototyping I
recommend deep and you know all the
animations just plot lib and I do
appreciate how frustrating can be it I
did come up with my own mechanism of
doing it fairly quickly now yeah thank
you very much
[Applause]
thank you yeah we have time for a couple
of questions yes the first one is
because I think a lot of people here be
more familiar with their ability based
optimization techniques right use it so
how is this if you know you have to
object there's this just stick to 2d you
have to object function each of the
functions a function composition you
have is my recent currents are trying to
what's going on here so you have what
are the surface actually look like the
decision space if you if you plot X is
the total convex is it non convex I say
okay people that use for this like I use
one based techniques like baby gradient
they say so any of those or that more
familiar you know techniques people
people from here yeah okay excellent
questions so hopefully I understood both
of them so the first one has to do with
what does what does our decision space
look like and the second has to do with
should we just have we applying gradient
descents yeah so in our case and imagine
also in the case of like the the
knapsack it's it's combinatorial and so
that means that any change like if you
take one like one package out or in that
you have like a very choppy choppy
landscape and that's the reason why
gradient descent is the best choice for
that yeah I think that kind of
summarizes both of your questions so you
you wouldn't you can't use great descent
if you know you have like smooth
decision spaces but once you get a
combinatorial yeah you kind of want to
go with multi objective and if it's very
large like
algorithms yeah and back yeah maybe now
okay so I just had a question about how
you do your objective optimization and
we'll just curious know if this is a
stupid question but after doing this
iteration on top of understanding things
about the protein sequences and so on
can you also understand for example like
that maybe some of the parameters are
not that important or you can limit the
parameter space of one of these
parameters so that you know maybe in the
next iteration it can be done more
quickly or you know you understand
something more about those parameters
yeah so your question is about the
parameters in the decision space
deciding if they're important or not
yeah so that's a very good question
that's something that I haven't gotten
to it has to do with optimizing your
optimizer how do you know if by tweaking
a few parameters or excluding part of
the decisions set if you're if you're
doing better or not yeah that's a whole
subject within its own the short answer
is that there are metrics to compare to
compare Pareto fronts in order to figure
out contributions of height of different
hyper parameters or different actually
that's a good question how do you
compare yeah I really have to think
about that maybe catch me in the pub
later on we can brainstorm that out cuz
I thought I had the answer and I started
saying something but I see that I got to
a roadblock here yeah but catch me later
yeah yes
height is it water no no but I so so the
question is sorry could you say so that
idea is you so your question is when I
do the optimization do I consider only
the Pareto front for the next iteration
or do I go back and look at
yeah okay so I'll try to answer it in
the sense that you want in the case of
proteins or the knapsack problem you
always want diversity the fact that you
rejected something in the past like you
do might want to take aspects of that
later and that's why you you want a
diverse in the terms of a decision space
you want a large diverse diverse
population so that if part of it is
rejected you know in the sequence space
maybe that part might be picked up later
on I don't know if that answers your
question yeah but I think the key is
diversity is even if something has been
rejected parts of it might be useful
later on and again like in the example I
showed it's a factor of 10 to the 26 one
asset that I didn't mention as the
optimizer it currently like treats
machine learning as God so like even if
you have a crappy model you have a
crappy optimization that goes without
saying but one has to always have that
you know take that into account that the
quality of the search depends on the
quality of in machine learning yes
in this case study I did the knife thing
I'm just taking the wild type the reason
being the wild type is something that we
know works in nature and and if you take
something like radical imagine this is a
combinatorial space of ten to the twenty
six if I would come up with the random
sequence then I would really rely
heavily on my machine learning to have
realistic biological predictions as
opposed to keeping close to your
training data so I showed that I match
to go like fifteen amino acids away from
the training data but if I had like
training data with variances of like 100
and length I seriously doubt that that I
get reliable results if you go like too
far away like you do want to stay close
to to the wild type but that's something
that we're still exploring yeah let's
wrap it up thanks here okay
[Applause]